[Musique]
alors marie van rijn bonjour dire cécile
robond jour merci à toutes les deux
dettes sur le plateau tv 78 pour ce vide
que l'on va vous consacrez vous êtes ici
en tant que vous êtes artiste cette
musicienne et enseignante clavecin et
talent et votre instrument ça fait et
vous cécile vous vous êtes de
responsable de l'action culturelle du
cmd vélo cmbv qui est le noeud centre de
musique baroque de versailles
très bien voilà donc vous êtes là pour
nous présenter un événement qui a un
petit peu des marais qui va durer sur
toute l'année scolaire j'entends c'est à
dire un événement qui s'appelle quatre
saisons de clavecin c'est une résidence
résidence extérieur voilà et puis on va
y revenir déjà j'aimerais moi qu'on
fasse ce mieux connaissance avec vous
marie g lucas 7 ans à calais donc de
calais vous saviez comment c'est les
clavecins c'est ça oui effectivement
j'ai commencé tout jeune cet instrument
est évidemment comme comme à cet âge là
au départ c c'est tout à fait de l'ordre
du loisir et puis c'est quelque chose
qui qui m'a quand même très bien
d'occuper est beaucoup plus et de plus
en plus intéressés donc
donc maintenant ça fait ça fait une
dizaine d'années maintenant j'en fais
mon métier
l'accord mère ma question c'est comment
à 7 ans ont dit tiens j'ai envie de
jouer du clavecin a quand même pas dire
laissons un petit peu désuet ou enfin -
- banalisée que la guitare ou là le
pipeau on nous donnait quand il est
moins connu que le piano violon mais
c'est c'est pas du tout désuète parce
qu'au contraire la musique ancienne ça
revient depuis vraiment déjà pas mal
d'années et pesant n'écoutiez elle
s'étend du baroque
oui alors j'écoutais toutes sortes de
musiques bateau c'était dans une famille
très mélomane pas musicienne mais très
mélomane et que donc ça allait de john
baez aux beatles et aux concertos
brandebourgeois d'accord d'accord et
vous peut-il vous êtes dit tiens le
clavecin matière oui en fait je voulais
faire du piano comme beaucoup on sait
moins original mais il fallait attendre
plusieurs années il y avait une liste
d'attentes parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
demandes souvent dans sa série noire
pour pour faire du piano et j'avais la
chance qu'il y ait un professeur de
clavecin qu'ils soient d'accord de ne
pas attendre la règle obligatoire des
deux années de formation musicale avant
de se mettre vraiment au concret à la
pratique de l'instrument et puis du coup
quand on m'a dit ensuite il y avait une
place en piano j'ai pas souhaité vous
avez tourné et fidèle voilà parce que le
cruiser quand on est tout jeune à ces
âges là ça compte énormément je
m'entendais très bien avec elle et donc
il n'y a pas de raison de changer et
puis même avant sa grâce à la pratique
de la flûte à bec de ma
r j'avais eu l'occasion de voir à quoi
ressemblait un clavecin donc à 7 ans
quand on m'a dit bon tu peux pas faire
du piano mais tu peux être inscrits dans
la classe de clavecin au moins je savais
comment sonne et un clavecin je voyais
quel instrument c'était donc ce n'était
pas non plus tout à fait une découverte
d'accord et vous donc vous êtes prise
d'affection d'intérêt d'amour de passion
pour cet instrument est ce répertoire et
au répertoire à savoir la musique
baroque
qu'est-ce qu'il ya marin marais y exhibe
est jacquet de la louvière et elad la
grande à la grande amie mais qui était
très très aimé et prisé de l'eau 14
c'est sa vie c'était il a protégé il a
toujours soutenu dans sa dans sa
carrière était compositeur aussi louis
xiv
non non elisabeth elisabeth a été
compositrice ben ouais elle risque c'est
que la bad continue parce qu'il ya
clavecin et basse continue son
d'instruments différents
alors c'est le même instrument mais la
basse continue en fait peut être
interprétée par un ensemble
d'instruments pas seulement par le
clavecin donc la bad continue c'est une
des pratiques des clavecinistes dans le
cadre de la musique d'ensemble
quand ils sont devant un orchestre ou
dans un ensemble c'est la façon de à
partir d'une ligne de basse on va à la
baisse continue au quai on va écouter
une petite vidéo bien sûr dit qu'est ce
tu as très bien professeur la basse
continue c'est un des grands bonheurs du
claveciniste je dirais parce que c'est
ce qui lui permet très vite de jouer au
centre d'un ensemble de jouer en groupe
que ce soit en formation en petite
formation musique de chambre ou en plus
grand de formation orchestrale avec voir
des soliste et un choeur également une
passe continue c'est aussi un travail
complet et apparentant claveciniste
parce qu'il faut se renseigner sur
comment on joue une passe continue en
allemagne au xviiie siècle
ou comment l'interpréter dans un style
français à paris alors dites moi ces
vidéos il y en a plusieurs qui sont
accessibles ces petites vidéos
explicatives vous les avez fait dans
quel but c'est récent
c'est dans le cadre du cmbv en fait
c'est dans le cadre des arts florissants
c'est qui c'est quoi les faire jouer
dans un orchestre et ensembles de
musique en siècle sa passe est analysé
et ça fait pas mal d'années et voilà que
je voyais avec à leur projet et c'est
eux qui m'avait demandé pour la
philharmonie et pour présenter aussi le
clavecin goujon qui fait partie des
collections le clac s'inquiéter qu'on a
vu sur la vidéo précédente celle qui
m'avait demandé de faire ses petites
vidéos sur différentes thématiques
d'accord je comprends alors revenons à
nos moutons du pays houdanais cécile ro
qu'est ce que c'est donc quatre saisons
de clavecin c'est donc le nom de la
résidence actuelle à laquelle vous êtes
conviés que vous que vous animez on va
dire parle pas tout seul mais
principalement dites moi un peu ce qui
est ce qu'il en est s'il vous plaît
alors oui c'est la première résidence
d'artistes que qu'organise le centre de
musique baroque de versailles en
territoire rural et l'idée c'était donc
de faire connaître une artiste d'une
jeune artiste et le répertoire de la
musique française qui est le répertoire
qu'on défend nous au centre de musique
baroque vie
et donc marie tu tues et envoyé en
mission
voilà sur le territoire soudanais le
pays d'où dans donkey est à une
communauté de communes
donc dans laquelle il y à la vidéo dans
mais il ya aussi la ville de richebourg
avec laquelle d'ailleurs on y va tout à
l'heure dans une école primaire et puis
d'autres petites communes boisset sivry
gresset l'idée c'est deux à la fois que
mari entouré d'autres artistes
travaillent
donc à la création d'oeuvres artistiques
fin voilà elle répète guy mongrain
production tout à fait donc son travail
d'artiste et aussi qu'elle en fasse
profitez en tout cas quelque elle en
profite pour faire toucher cette musique
là part aux habitants qu'ils connaissent
mal peu et le répertoire est
l'instrument puisque le sel quand même
loyettes au sein de la résidence l'idée
c'est vraiment de rencontrer plein de
types de publics différents
en fait oui c'est vous qui allez à
l'encontre du public
voilà vous leur proposez donc des master
class vous leur proposez alors des
masters que la norme tout de suite parce
qu'il faut déjà avoir fait à peu près
dix ans de musique
j'arrêterai mieux mais en tout cas
effectivement on fait d'actions turenne
qui sont très variés et quand cette voie
là puisque j'ai rencontré déjà dans tout
début de résidence des collégiens on a
travaillé avec deux collègues sur une
avec une classe avec deux classes de
collégiens
on a aussi un copain différentes écoles
primaires qu'on va vivre et en fait
concrètement le travail d'artistes en
résidence c'est comme disait cécile de
répéter d'imaginer de construire des
programmes
mais ces répétitions elles sont ouvertes
si elles se font sur
sur un territoire précis vous dans un
lieu c'est bon ça c'est mon col d'un
hôpital au lieu d'être au théâtre ou
dans un conservatoire vous dans des
lieux habituels finalement de la
pratique musicale ça se passe ailleurs
parce que ça permet aussi du coup à
différentes personnes de passer devant
la salle à qu'est ce que c'est un club
sain et puis on prie on planifie aussi
des moments de rencontres et d'ateliers
plus plus concret aussi donc pas par
exemple alors bas par exemple en fait
donc des ateliers déjà de découverte de
l'instrument parce que vous mentionnez
c'est pas très connu par rapport à
d'autres saleh de plus en plus mais ça
allait pas encore partout et puis aussi
des ateliers qui leur permettent aussi
de découvrir vraiment le répertoire
défendue par le centre de musique
baroque de versailles ses terres 2e
répertoire français qui est vraiment un
patrimoine un patrimoine pour la france
souffre avec tous les grands
compositeurs qu'on a eu et à confondre
avec le répertoire italien par exemple
par exemple ou avec le répertoire
germanique
oui oui tout à fait vraiment une école
de clavecin de 2
logisticien français tout à fait il ya
une grosse écurie a vendu 16 lors du 17e
siècle et puis on va aussi on ouvre sur
dix huitième siècle
mais de toute cette période qui est la
grande période du classement donc des
xviie et xviiie siècles les comment
agissent les enfants des collèges ou
même plus jeunes devant ce clavecin
parce que c'est un peu fragile par
rapport à un vrai piano ou est-ce que
fragile juillet mais bon ça se
désaccordent vite mais en tout cas ils
sont alors je pense que les jeunes c'est
toujours un instrument qui attire le
clavier c'est quelque chose qui est qui
a acquis un abord qui peut être immédiat
qui est très agréable et accessible est
tout jeune et puis au clavecin sac dès
qu'on leur présente en montrant la
mécanique exactement comment le son est
fabriqué en démontant un peu là
exactement tout de suite ils sont ils
sont très intéressés dès que ça rentre
tout de suite dans l'aspect entre
guillemets bricolage de vraiment entrer
donc la mécanique de l'instrument et
c'est un angle d'approché pour ensuite
parler des musiques qui peuvent être
joués sur cet instrument qui sont pas
que des musiques anciennes parce qu'on
parle pas lors des 17e et 18e
mais justement dans le projet qu'on fait
avec les collégiens le but c'est de
croiser avec les musiques actuelles et
la loi pour ça le il ya une ingénieur du
son qui que j'ai invités à réaliser des
coupes juste votre résidence allez
faites vous êtes entouré d'autres
artistes par moments voilà une
expression précise le marmot cécile le
but quand le cmb vma m'a appelé pour
proposer ce projet il voulait centré
autour du clavecin parce que c'est quand
même un instrument très déçu à l'antenne
de cette période et qui a le grand
avantage de pouvoir se suffire vraiment
à lui même en solo il ya plusieurs dates
prévues également
deux procès recevoir seul et puis c'est
un instrument très sociable parce que
c'est comme on disait par la pratique de
la base continue un instrument qui va
soutenir se marier accompagné beaucoup
d'autres instruments feintool est
d'accord donc la raf en revenir à notre
musique plus contemporaine vous avez
fait appel avant que je ne vous coupe la
parole vous aviez dire à un autre
artiste pour les collégiens c'est une
ingénieur du son et narratrice sonore
est là les professeurs de hama où
musique assistée par ordinateur mao et
clavecin voilà le but c'est que on
ajoute on sonorise l'instrument on
ajoute des micros et on va arriver
rajouter des effets qu'on cherche là sur
lesquels on travaille ensemble des
effets sonores qui permettent de croiser
à partir du répertoire du xviie de faire
le pont aussi d'aller vers les musiques
actuelles donc vous créer des ponts
voilà entre des publics comme cela n'est
ce pas des publics qui ont vite créé
avec vous et comment voir alors ce
résultat par exemple il ya plusieurs
dates de concert ou à la fois les jeunes
qui auront participé aux ateliers et et
les moins jeunes puisqu'il ya aussi le
public oui ça va jusqu'aux autres
personnes âgées hospitalisées soit ils
vont être invités au concert et puis ces
concerts bien sûr ça sera pas seulement
pour les personnes ayant assisté aux
actions culturelles et ateliers vous
mais comme on dit tout à l'heure aussi
pour tous ceux que les habitants qui est
du pays où des et qui veulent
s'intéresser à ces différentes musiques
et venir découvrir des projets en tout
cas c'est vraiment pour oser super
public vous adorez vous ça le contact
avec les élèves
les jeunes les liquides les clients mais
c'est en place dans le métier d'artiste
c'est justement de partage et qu'en fait
la musique a priori bon bah on la fait
pas pour soi tout seul maintenant c'est
ce que je vois merci beaucoup marie
alors de nous faire participer à toutes
vos belles créations
cécile on oubliait des choses où tout va
bien je crois pas d'accord ça va
connaître le programme tout à fait alors
il y aura comme il ya plusieurs concerts
en perspective juin je vous invite à
aller consulter
quatre saisons de clavecin bon qu'il
faut taper 4 saisons avec saison au
pluriel de clavecin et puis vous aurez
toutes les dates
voilà et bien voilà y'a plus qu'à et
c'est gratuit sans réservation et tout
est gratuit sans réservation tout à fait
génial
marie-cécile un gros merci merci et à
bientôt
à bientôt et merci beaucoup d'être venus
et merci
[Musique]